T
ZELENY HAS MORE.
>> I KNOWYLOVEMING.
AND WIELDS IT LIKE A HAMMECHENEM
WYOMG'
THAT VIRAEN WHO CURRENY ITr: THY
TROUBLE FOR EYAS N WYOMASCHENEY
END.
IT WASN'ALT WA I'M PROUDO INTRO
>> A PROVEUS TUTIONAL CONSERVAT
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
STATION. eporteT'OR WYOMIN A NNA
E SAME DAY CHENEY N AND NOW HE L
A STATE WHERE HE WON 70%
VOTE.
HIS WIST. INT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE BETRAYEDS. VER ANA GREATER G
E THAN A
E.
E MINENCN
IGE FEDERAL
THAT WE D RESOURCES.
PROTECT THE ENERGYTRY NOT
WYOMING BUTOR
WYOMING ISSUESESONATED WITH
MANY VOTERS WE MET LRLY FOE'S DR
OR VE R LICHENEY?
>> FOR HER
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE RNOFF'
LATELY ARE NOT ONE
ARE HIND          OUGHTO E ANGE
HEY CAN GASLIGHT U WHEN WE CAUG
DEINUR
QUESTIONS.
LAST WEEK SH  AN AIDD INYED VO
SS ELEN
RHT A CAMPAIGN STOP IN. Y THE TI
IT WAS RIGGED TOAKRE
NOTE                       ECTE
Rr: WHAT SHE DOESN'TELL HER AU
D TRP ANORTED TED
HSFORMATION FROM CHENEY ALLRUM
>> I'LL TAKE THE FIGD.C.
JUST AS S I DEFEAT LIZ
O REPUBLICANS ALL
WEEK LONG YO
SHE'S IN A VERMMANDIEAING INTO .
SPO H
CE IF SHE HAS ONE AT ALLRATS ANL